Goldman Sachs is planning a round of
company-wide layoffs this month joining
the growing list of major corporations
and large companies who've done the same
out of fear of a looming recession the
investment bank usually lays off one to
five percent of its workers every year
as part of annual performance reviews
but suspended the program during the
pandemic here's a look at some of the
other big names that have been trimming
their Workforce this summer 2500
employees of the online used car seller
carvana received an email from CEO Ernie
Garcia saying they would be let go that
was 12 percent of the company's
Workforce about 1 100 coinbase employees
learned they had been laid off after
losing access to their work emails
marking an 18 reduction in the crypto
company's staff CEO Brian Armstrong said
the move was essential to staying
healthy during this economic downturn JP
Morgan Chase America's largest bank laid
off and reassigned more than one
thousand of its over 270 000 employees
citing Rising mortgage rates and
increased inflation real estate firm Max
announced plans to lay off 17 percent of
its Workforce by the end of 2022. the
company's staged goal is bringing in 100
million dollars in annual mortgage
related Revenue by 2028. Tesla laid off
229 employees mostly in its autopilot
Division and shut down its office in San
Mateo California
7-Eleven cut 880 U.S corporate jobs just
over a year after it completed a 21
billion dollar deal to purchase Speedway
Shopify cut 1 000 employees or 10
percent of its Workforce after
determining demand for online shopping
during the pandemic has leveled off
online crypto brokerage Robinhood cut 23
percent of its staff with CEO Vlad
tennis setting a drop in trading
activity High inflation and a broad
crypto market crash the company had
already laid off nine percent of its
full-time employees in April Ford
announced it will let go about 3 000
office and contract employees to cut
spending as it transitions to producing
electric vehicles
snap CEO Evan Spiegel announced in a
memo that the social media company will
lay off 1280 employees or 20 percent as
the company is facing a lower rate of
Revenue growth the company's stock price
has plummeted nearly 80 percent since
earlier this year and finally Investment
Banking giant Credit Suisse could cut as
many as 5 000 jobs as the Scandal hit
Bank seeks to turn around its reputation
and reduce costs
[Music]